hi it's time to work on Silver City now
in this episode I'm actually going to
build some buildings that kind of mimic
the way that some buildings look that
I've already placed before like this
building is kind of going to be like
that one other building I don't even
know how to explain this really but it's
an it's in the middle of that one square
with the office buildings and all that
but yeah it's it's kind of going to be
similar I just felt like I would mess
around with different designs and such
because I felt like maybe I could
actually mimic some buildings throughout
the city so that it actually looks like
it all fits together in a sense and I
might as well just take the chance to
just work on some general ideas on
things really so well that's going to be
the first part of this episode now the
second part I'm actually going to build
another skyscraper it's not going to be
a very big one it's just going to be a
somewhat standard boring skyscraper
that's not even that high I just kind of
felt like I need to flesh out the
skyline because we've got a couple of
somewhat high towers with spires and all
that and you kind of need some somewhat
lower skyscrapers around that as well
just to kind of create a bit of contrast
between the interesting buildings and
the not so interesting buildings and of
course there is a huge there is a huge
jump when it comes to height because
right now we've got some very low
buildings and some apps like weird hi
skyscrapers and there's no real
borderline between that but yeah this
building is pretty simple it's similar
to that other building but using some
more weird stuff that I just I just
thought of I was like oh well I find
those pieces and I kind of wanted to
experiment with Bodines class and good
news and it came out pretty decent so
that's cool but yeah this building is
pretty much finished at this point I do
want people to note though that this
little street and especially this
building but the other one as well is
kind of inspired by Dutch classicism so
that's why it kind of looks like that
and it kind of reflects many buildings
in Holland as well and the second
building is actually going to be kind of
like the building on that the first
little thing well basically it's the
first
I built in series except it's going to
be a little bit more Main Street ish I
don't know what kind of building I want
it to be it's just the same idea except
we don't really have that glass thing
going on on the roof with this one I'm
going to build two towers on both sites
but we do have that nice little corner
balcony because I like that idea for
some reason now really there's nothing
else to say about this release to stay
somewhat simple building considering the
fact I've already built something like
it in this episode and today is it's
just been a very weird day for me it's
well it hasn't really been weird
honestly I just made it weird because I
didn't have that much school so went to
school came home I was like I've loads
of school work to do and I was like I'm
just gonna watch a bit of enemy and it
was that mood where you get into okay
that was a good episode I'll do one more
episode and then I'll do my homework and
then it's late in the evening and APSCo
water polo practice and then I'm like
mmm well I don't want to do my homework
i'm going to record a roller coaster in
three videos so here we are so that's
beautiful so my my life is strange
sometimes or at least I make it strange
please I'm stupid sometimes what will we
be talking about so yeah I don't know
why I'm talking about that that the
building is not that interesting really
I feel like it's probably a bit too
similar to the other building that's why
I don't even finish it in this episode I
decide to I I decided to be a total
idiot I just be like man this building
is mad I'm not gonna remove it but I'm
not going to finish it either yet I'm
just going to move on or something so
I'm not even going to finish this thing
in this episode however I do kind of
look the way that it looks and
especially from the one square in the
middle of the town it has a pretty nice
for you on it don't know what I'm going
to do with the little plot of land next
to it i think i'm gonna place a building
or something like that over there but
I'm very much afraid of my city becoming
too much of a concrete jungle but then
again I am always obsessed with placing
flowers and trees and plants everywhere
so perhaps I should not be too afraid of
getting a concrete jungle because my
definition of that might be
different from the mainstream definition
of that really so yeah awesome spires
and really I feel like is this even
realistic because that's what I kind of
asked myself because of course the main
street set is kind of their to mimic the
American American okay sorry I need to
stop doing that whole evoke but it kind
of it kind of mimics the American style
of building stuff i guess but then again
i'm still very much afraid of my
buildings ending up looking like
something that you'd place in a theme
park but all in all I'm pretty happy
with these little towers and of course
the the middle stuff is the boring stuff
so I'm just gonna be me and
procrastinate that and silver at be like
screw this building also screw airplanes
sat because it was glitching at the
moment you could see their little black
stones they're not supposed to be black
like that but yeah I was like silver at
be like yeah I'm gonna skip that and I'm
gonna move on I'm gonna move on and work
on something else now this is going to
turn into the worst copy/paste nightmare
I've ever had so if you don't know about
the copy paste method it's something
that you generally can't live without
when you're building skyscrapers in
Lagos taken three it's not to be cheap
really you shoot not copy paste anything
in rolla costa country especially not
foliage it may save a lot of time but
it's gonna end up looking unrealistic in
the end but skyscrapers is probably yeah
you're probably not going to be able to
actually build one without actually
using copy paste because if you built
one without it you're probably going to
spend like eight hours placing all the
pieces especially considering how high
they are I don't think you can even
build a skyscraper of a decent height
without copy paste simply because you
can't raise objects that high so what
you what you'd normally do is you raise
an object then you save it and then you
place it again and save that as an
object and then raise it again and until
you reach like your desired ridiculous
height but basically I decided to do
that kind of method with this as well do
the first two floors copy
taste it and then place it what copy it
really and then place it but as you can
see that the first wall is kind of
messed up and you can see the thing on
the site there because of obviously
since that being is on a hostile
placement I'm going to copy part of the
walls of the building next to it as well
so that that was kind of unfortunate so
now I'm left with this mess and windows
was being annoying as well so that's why
you just saw that screen I'm sorry for
that and yeah so also i missed the front
that was really stupid so i'm going to
mess with that the front as well as you
can see and that doesn't work out either
so then i have to remove all of that
again so what should you do in this case
do not be done like me well there's
something you can do is opening an empty
sample sandbox and building your
building in that that's what i usually
do i'm pretty sure that that's what i
did with a real gun and it's great for
many reasons it saves you loads of like
you don't have to work with a lag like i
have to in these videos because my pc is
that terrible and also of course you
don't have to worry about copy pasting
the environment or not copy pasting
something that you need to actually get
but the only thing with that is i didn't
want to make a separate park file to
make my towers in simply because i'm
recording and you wouldn't see the
progress as nicely as you can now though
then again when I decided when I when I
decided to go for this method I didn't
realize that I would later on be an
idiot and actually do it like this and
mess everything up but I think in the
end I think at this point the building
is pretty much finished except for the
fact that I raised the first two floors
a bit too high so that was dumb as well
but in hindsight it was actually pretty
cool because now I can add that little
border over there and that's awesome and
now the roof is also going to be
somewhat annoying because I felt like
okay I want some kind of a cool roof
just a nice little cornice corners ish
kind of thing but the only problem that
I had was trying to find good roof
pieces and stuff like that so
yeah and the end i meddle with that for
a very long time as well so great city
building adventures and really what I
find actually is that I build the best
stuff once I try it for the second time
I don't know when oh yeah I remember
when I did that it was in my normal
roller coaster in three let's play that
I recorded a station me building a
station for my wing wider and it turned
out to be the most crappy station I've
ever seen it was it was it was a
disaster and so I decided to throw away
that station open my backup file and
remove the videos and decided to work on
something else and then that came out
pretty well and also with one of the
Silver City episodes but I can't exactly
remember which one it was and anymore I
built a building and I was like it was
ugly turd of a building I didn't want to
do anything with that but then I removed
that and decided to record it again and
built something else and then that
turned out to be something really cool
I'm actually I actually think that was
the main tower yeah that was the main
town with the prism shaped tower at the
center of the town oh that's actually
pretty cool but yeah this building it is
somewhat simple I feel like this
building is very realistic though and it
kind of made the city although it does
ruin the skyline from some angles but
not really too sure about that and of
course and everyone's entitled to their
opinions it does make the city look more
realistic in a sense so thank you for
watching and see you in the next episode